c’est toi qui pue là ?
Hmmm !
Non mais y’a une odeur, sérieux
Rendors toi, c’est trop tôt…
Les keywords que j’avais et…
WOOH...
Just a sec !
ça schlingue ici quand même, vous ne voulez pas ouvrir les fenêtres ?
Quand on dit “roux, rouquins, rousseaux…” ou tout simplement “Poil de carotte”,
on désigne en général une personnes qui a des cheveux plus ou moins oranges,
mais en écrivant cet épisode j’ai remarqué que la vie c’est pas comme dans les dessins animés.
Il existe une grande variété de nuances de “roux”,
du blond avec des reflets oranges clair jusqu’au roux sombre.
Moi par exemple selon les coiffeurs, la nuance de couleur de mes cheveux c’est
“camel”.
A l’échelle mondiale, on trouve des roux partout,
et ils représentent environ 2% de la population,
et plus généralement en Europe,
mais aussi dans certaines populations au Maghreb,
au Proche-Orient… et dans les iles Salomons.
Pour affiner cette définition de roux, je me suis intéressée à l’origine de la couleur de cheveux
et plus précisément aux mélanocytes,
des cellules un peu spéciales présentes dans notre peau,
notre cuir chevelu, nos iris et même dans notre tube digestif.
Ce sont des cellules assez mignonnes, avec des ptits bras par lesquels
sont distribués des pigments biologiques
qui déterminent la couleur.
Et ces pigments, ce sont les mélanines, dont les magazines féminins nous reparlent tous les étés…
En fait il existe 2 types de mélanines :
la phéomélanine qui est un pigment jaune-rouge que tout le monde produit
et l’eumélanine, un pigment marron-noir,
le même que celui qui nous fait bronzer.
La couleur visible des poils et des cheveux dépend de la quantité d’eumélanine présente,
qui peut varier considérablement.
Si l’eumélanine est présente en grandes quantités, la couleur est très sombre,
et moins il y en a plus la couleur tend de façon continue vers le châtain, le blond puis le roux.
Et quand il n’y a aucune des mélanines, la personne est albinos et ses cheveux sont quasi blancs.
Clairement, toi, t’es rousse.
Non, ce n’est pas si évident.
Quand tu mélanges du noir et du orange, à partir de quel moment tu vas passer de “c’est plutôt orange” à “c’est plutôt noir” ?
- Ouais d’accord, c’est comme entre chauve et pas chauve quoi ?
- Voilà !
Par contre, toi, t’es clairement chauve.
Attend, les roux ils ont des taches de rousseur,
c’est pas pour rien que ça s’appelle comme ça.
Oui mais, Marie aussi elle a des taches de rousseur, est-ce qu’elle est rousse ?
Non. Je suis pas rousse. Non.
Y a un chercheur qui a essayé en 1952
qui a fait le test.
Il a analysé les cheveux et il a vu que dedans,
il y avait de la phéomélanine partout
et que ça variait de façon continue.
Du brun au roux, on avait de moins en moins de mélanine.
Donc, dire roux, pas roux, c’est arbitraire.
Attend mais là, c’est le petit-déj.
Personne ne va retenir ça, surtout après la soirée d’hier. D’ailleurs, vous êtes passés où vous ?
Eh oui même si la couleur de cheveux des enfants peut changer dans les premières années de la vie,
la couleur de nos cheveux à l'âge adulte est héréditaire.
Donc tout naturellement je suis allée voir du côté de la génétique pour tenter d'y trouver une raison à l'odeur des roux.
Dans la membrane de nos mélanocytes, il y a un récepteur qui, lorsqu'il en reçoit le signal, déclenche la production d’eumélanine.
En l'absence de signal, c’est la phéomélanine uniquement est produite.
La forme de ce récepteur est codée par un gène nommé
comme le récepteur : “MelanoCortin 1 Receptor”
ou MC1R,
situé chez l’homme sur le Chromosome 16.
Quand ce gène comporte des mutations, le récepteur a une forme qui lui permet moins bien de reconnaître le signal,
et il déclenche alors moins souvent la production d’eumélanine.
C’est de là que vient l’explication simpliste de l’origine de la rousseur, que l'on croise souvent.
Sauf que non.
Déjà dans les années 90, les généticiens ont découvert que différentes mutations du gène MC1R
pouvaient entraîner une chevelure rousse.
Mais en 2018, grâce aux nouvelles banques de données fournies par les tests ADN grand public,
une étude menée sur près de 350 000 profils génétiques au Royaume-Uni,
a montré que le gène MC1R ne serait pas responsable
à lui-seul de la couleur rousse.
La majorité des personnes porteuses des mutations de ce gène sur leurs 2 allèles sont d’ailleurs blondes ou châtain clair.
L’étude montre ainsi que pas moins de 8 autres gènes seraient impliqués dans l’apparition de la rousseur,
modifiant la forme du récepteur ou inhibant la production d’eumélanine.
Et les chercheurs ont au passage recensé près de 200 versions différentes du gène MC1R.
Donc non, être roux ne se réduit pas à l’histoire d’un simple gène.
Tout comme la couleur de la peau, la rousseur est un caractère polygénique.
Ce qui n’est finalement pas très difficile à croire quand on regarde la très grande diversité des couleurs et des types de cheveux que l’on rassemble
sous cette même appellation “ROUX”.
Du coup, y’a des parents roux qui peuvent avoir des enfants pas roux,
et y a même des jumeaux identiques qui naissent,
un roux et un pas roux.
Tu sais qu’on peut parler d’autre chose.
Et l’odeur, alors ?
L’odeur corporelle est propre à chaque individu, et elle est encore plus caractéristique que l’ADN
puisque deux jumeaux n’auront pas la même odeur corporelle.
Elle comprend plusieurs composantes qui varient au cours de la vie, en fonction de la santé,
de l’alimentation, de l’hygiène, des hormones, des émotions, etc…
mais aussi une composante de fond, génétiquement acquise.
Puisqu’on cherche une odeur liée au caractère héréditaire “ROUX”,
on va chercher du côté de cette composante de fond, qui est déterminée par la nature des sécrétions de la peau
et les bactéries qui la peuplent.
Oui parce que, attention, ça va peut-être vous choquer,
mais les sécrétions de la peau ne sont pas parfumées.
Contrairement à ce qu’on pourrait croire, ça n’est pas la sueur elle-même qui pue !
Ce sont les bactéries hébergées sur notre peau
qui se chargent de transformer les molécules diluées dans la transpiration en un nuage de puanteur.
Donc une odeur différente, ce sont des sécrétions de la peau différentes
et / ou des bactéries différentes.
Mais chercher une odeur de la peau propre aux rousses et aux roux, ça implique un premier raccourci discutable :
le caractère "ROUX" concerne la couleur de cheveux…
pas la peau.
Beaucoup de bruns ou de blonds ont ce qu'on appelle "une peau de roux",
très claire par exemple
ou avec des taches de rousseur comme Marie.
Non mais, je ne suis pas rousse, tu arrêtes avec ça.
Bof.
Donc eux aussi devraient puer.
Ensuite, être roux, on l’a vu,
c’est tout un ensemble de couleurs qui apparaissent “par défaut”
à cause des très faibles doses d’eumélanine dans les poils, les cheveux, et souvent dans la peau.
Les scientifiques ayant montré que l’autre pigment, la phéomélanine, est présent dans toutes les peaux,
et si on imagine comme Madame le Figaro par exemple,
que la source de l’odeur des roux c’est cette phéomélanine,
bah tout le monde devrait dégager cette odeur.
Déso.
Sans compter que ce raisonnement passe sous silence que les pigments ne sont détectés qu’en quantités
infimes dans la sueur, alors qu’elle contient par ailleurs
plein d’autres molécules sécrétées par la peau en bien plus grandes quantités,
identifiées elles comme les précurseurs des mauvaises odeurs.
Plus précisément, les sécrétions de la peaux proviennent de 3 types de glandes :
Leur sécrétion riche en lipides et en stéroïdes est déclenchée par l’adrénaline
et les poils permettent la diffusion des sécrétions.
Ce mélange de molécule suffit déjà à produire un beau bouquet odorant.
Les lipides en particulier, sont dégradés par les bactéries en acides gras,
dont certains avec une odeur aigre et piquante
qui attirent les moustiques,
et d’autres avec des odeurs plus herbacées ou fruitées,
qui sont même utilisés en additifs alimentaires…
Bon, si ce n’est pas directement la phéomélanine,
on peut toujours regarder du côté du fameux gène MC1R et de ses 200 variantes.
Même si l’apparition du caractère roux est polygénique, peut être que certaines mutations qui donnent les cheveux roux impactent aussi les sécrétions cutanées ?
Ou le type de bactéries qui peuplent la peau ?
Eh bien pour tout vous dire, j’ai eu beau chercher,
je n'ai rien trouvé.
Et pourtant, j’ai trouvé des études sur les liens entre le gène MC1R et les processus de réparation de l’ADN,
la résistance à l’anesthésie et à la douleur et même… avec la sorcellerie…
Donc j’ai essayé de retrouver l’histoire, l’origine du préjugé quoi.
Et j’ai essayé de trouver des textes qui le mentionnaient.
Et là, je ne trouve pas grand chose à part éventuellement, la plus ancienne source, ce serait Aristote,
qui aurait dit dans un texte que la rousseur était une infirmité du poil.
Je ne vais pas te laisser dire n’importe quoi sur Aristote quand même.
Tu peux parler de ma calvitie, mais Aristote, on ne déconne pas.
Cette phrase là, le roux serait une infirmité du poil, elle n’existe pas chez Aristote.
C’est souvent répété même encore aujourd’hui, mais vraiment dans toute l’œuvre d’Aristote,
il n’y a quasi pas de mention de la rousseur et en tout cas, pas cette phrase là.
Ce qu’on a par contre, c’est un traité qui s’appelle “
Physiognomica”,
qui a eu beaucoup d’importance au XIXe siècle, on aime même beaucoup le lire parce que ça rejoignait beaucoup d’idées qui étaient très en vogue au XIXe siècle.
Cette idée de lire le caractère des gens sur leur physionomie.
Et effectivement, dans ce traité là qui est plein d’horreur par ailleurs,
il y a aussi un passage sur les roux, qui sont comparés au renard parce que c’est la même couleur et les renards sont plutôt fourbes.
Donc, les roux seraient fourbes.
C’est pas très sympa.
En tout cas ce traité, même s’il a été attribué à Aristote pendant très longtemps.
De fait, il n’est pas d’Aristote, et cette obsession sur les roux, elle ne semble vraiment pas venir des Grecques pour autant que je sache.
Du coup, bah, je ne sais pas,
à l’Antiquité, comment étaient jugés les roux
Alors, la connotation sur la rousseur, à l’Antiquité, ce n’est pas lié aux odeurs.
Enfin, chez les Grecques.
Chez les Grecques, Pyhrros, roux,
c’est un adjectif qu’on utilise pour qualifier les barbares, et principalement les barbares qui viennent du Nord,
couplé à l’adjectif glaucos, donc les yeux bleus, pairs,
les deux ensembles, ça connote un aspect inquiétant, mais
aussi une ardeur guerrière, une fougue, indomptable, etc.
Donc, dangereuse et violente.
Par contre, c’est rarement quelque chose qui qualifie le Grec lambda.
On va dire. Mais néanmoins, ça peut paraître contradictoire, c’est quand même un prénom Pyrrhos,
chez les Grecs. Il y a des rois qui se sont appelés comme ça.
Donc, on pourrait se dire : “étrange, un prénom connoté comme ça pour des rois.”
Pas si étrange, car c’est quand même un adjectif qu’on utilise pour qualifier Achille, le plus grand des héros de la Guerre de Troie,
qui dans son adolescence était roux.
On l’appelait Achille le Roux, mais quand il était jeune.
Avec toujours cette idée de fougue, de la jeunesse indomptable etc.,
mais quand Achille devient adulte et qu’il part à la Guerre de Troie, on le qualifie plutôt de blond.
Et le blond, c’est doré, c’est la couleur des Dieux, la lumière, etc.
Donc, il y a une connotation pas forcément très positive avec l’adjectif roux.
Mais bon, ça peut quand même être un prénom de roi. Mais en tout cas, pas d’association avec une odeur particulière à ma connaissance.
Donc, c’est vraiment une espèce de reprise au XIXe siècle d’idées qu’on avait plus ou moins dire à l’Antiquité,
auquel on rajoute des préjugés qui sont juste de cette époque là.
La méfiance envers les roux et les idées reçues existent donc depuis bien longtemps,
et sont intensifiés dans les sociétés judéo chrétiennes,
mais la mention de la mauvaise odeur des roux est étrangement assez récente…
Les premières références littéraires et scientifiques sur l’odeur des roux remontent en fait aux années 1800.
Gustave Flaubert écrit ainsi en 1857 dans Madame Bovary :
L’odeur des roux pénétrait à travers la muraille, pendant les consultations,
de même que l’on entendait de la cuisine, les malades tousser dans le cabinet et débiter toute leur histoire.
Mais ce sont dans les ouvrages scientifiques de l’époque  que l’on retrouve le plus d’allusions au parfum roux...
Il faut dire que dans la deuxième moitié du 19e siècle, les odeurs deviennent une préoccupation centrale dans la société.
Alors qu’aux siècles précédents, clairement, ça pue la mort,
une véritable sensibilité olfactive voit le jour,
notamment grâce au développement de l’hygiène et des parfums.
Les odeurs corporelles, alors intimement liées à la morale, font l’objet de tout un tas de traités scientifiques,
à une époque où les médecins raffolent des typologies
et analysent des moindres détails de la physiologie des corps, en particulier du corps féminin.
Les experts es odeurs de l’époque, établissent alors une classification des odeurs corporelles en fonction de la couleur de peau,
et y associent la couleur de cheveux.
Le Docteur Augustin Galopin, de loin mon hygiéniste préféré du 19e siècle,
établit ainsi en 1886 dans "Le Parfum de la femme et le sens olfactif dans l’amour",
11 catégories d’odeur de femmes,
Depuis “1° la négresse et la mulâtresse avec toutes les nuances de chocolat
ou de pain d’épices,
à 11° la rousse pure tavelée, cheveux et poils abondants, peau blanche
tachée de son, quelquefois des yeux noirs d’une originalité toute particulière,
regard étrange et fascinateur,
de belles dents, des lèvres ou minces à l’excès ou charnelles ;
souvent affectées de ptyalisme
qui n’est pas sans inconvénient et sans odeur ; parfum très caractéristique, fin ou très recherché.”
Le ptyalisme c’est l'excès de salive.
La médecine du 19e siècle, se nourrit forcément des représentations sociales de l’époque,
et contribue parfois à les justifier par des explications scientifiques.
(Pour vous situer, c’est cette belle époque où l’on justifie scientifiquement le colonialisme)
Le docteur Charles Féré, tentent donc dès 1892 de relier les sécrétions de la peau et l’odeur des roux :
“Les odeurs des sécrétions cutanées varient beaucoup suivant les individus, les roux ont souvent une odeur plus pénétrante.”
Avant que le docteur Ernest Monin, propose enfin en 1904
une explication scientifique à cette spécificité :
“Beaucoup de personnes, et particulièrement les femmes rousses, exhalent,
lorsqu'elles ont très chaud, une odeur sure, fort désagréable,
qui est due aux acides valérianique et caproïque éliminés par la sueur.”
Une explication qui semblerait bancale aujourd’hui, mais tout à fait plausible avec les connaissances de l’époque
(quand même 100 ans avant Madame Le Figaro),
ces deux acides ayant été tout juste découverts et produits pour la parfumerie.
Au 19e, on découvre aussi les sulfureux écrits du Marquis de Sade,
et en 1904 justement,
"Les 120 journées de Sodome ou l'école du libertinage", rédigé pendant sa captivité à la Bastille
et publié pour la première fois en version complète
et annoté scientifiquement
par le docteur allemand Ivan Bloch.
Parmi les 600 perversions et sévices sexuels présentés,
le Marquis de Sade mentionne un homme qui affectionne particulièrement les odeurs de transpiration sous les aisselles des femmes,
et pour qui on fait venir une jeune fille rousse.
Le psychiatre annote là :
“Le cas No. 22 décrit un fétichiste olfactif, qui, comme on sait,
préfère les femmes rousses, dont l'odeur est particulièrement forte,
ainsi que de Sade l'explique aussi dans ce cas.”
Et effet, on retrouve un peu plus loin un personnage qui explique que :
“Ces femmes-là, vous ne l’ignorez point, Monseigneur, ont dans cette partie un fumet infiniment plus violent.”
Le préjugé de l’odeur est l’un des rares qui est attribué aux hommes comme aux femmes,
mais il se retrouve beaucoup plus souvent mentionné pour les femmes
et ces écrits montrent combien il est lié à la sexualité.
Depuis le moyen âge, la rousseur des femmes est en général associée au péché,
or au 19e siècle, l‘odeur est justement utilisée pour dénigrer les prostituées.
Donc le lien odeur-sexualité-rousse est quasi immédiat et devient très populaire.
Et le kink pour l'odeur des rousses trouve un intérêt particulier aux yeux des médecins
alors que la psychiatrie se développe et que la sexologie voit le jour.
L’historienne de la littérature Valérie André a justement exploré toutes les références aux roux et rousses,
et elle note que le préjugé sur l’odeur a aussi parcouru les 19e et 20e siècles dans une multitude de romans,
à travers des personnages féminins.
Nana la prostituée rousse de Zola,
la fille de Charles Swann dans À la recherche du temps perdu de Proust,
la mère Vitruve dans Mort à crédit de Céline.
Autant de rousses dont l’odeur est mentionnée plus ou moins subtilement.
Et évidemment, plus proche de nous, "Le parfum", publié par l’auteur allemand Susskind en 1985 et récemment adapté en série Netflix,
repose sur ce même préjugé.
Du coup, les roux ne puent pas.
Non, c’est principalement la faute au 19e siècle que tout le monde s’est mis à penser ça.
C’est quoi le rapport avec le 19e siècle ?
Mais Chouchou, tout a un rapport avec le 19e siècle.
Alors oui c’est sûr, il y a quelques siècles, il y avait beaucoup plus d’odeurs corporelles qu’aujourd’hui,
et on sentait surement beaucoup plus les différences entre les gens.
Mais est-ce qu’on pouvait identifier une odeur particulière associée à un groupe de personnes aussi divers que les roux ?
Et pourquoi la mentionner si tard ?
Dans tous les cas, l’odeur reste un puissant moteur de discrimination puisqu’elle est encore peu expliquée scientifiquement,
et surtout parce qu’elle fait appel aux sens et pas à la raison.
Et les études sociologiques montrent que la mauvaise odeur fait partie des premiers attributs donnés à la race inférieure dans les idéologies racistes,
juste après “C'est des sauvages” et juste avant “ils mangent des trucs dégueux”.
Donc, tout me pousse à penser que le “parfum des roux” est juste une construction sociale
qui est venue alimenter une discrimination sur le physique qui existait déjà.
Ouais enfin, tu dis ça parce que, contrairement à moi, toi, t’es rousse, c’est tout.
*Manon toussote*
J'avoue que j’ai moi-même grandi avec l’idée reçue que les roux sentent différemment,
et en me lançant dans cet épisode, je m'attendais vraiment à tomber sur une explication médicale au préjugé,
ou sur une étude bien ficelée qui prouve le contraire…
Mais non.
je n'ai rien trouvé qui traite directement du sujet.
(D’ailleurs, si on vous prétend qu’une telle étude scientifique existe, méfiez-vous, y a de fortes chances que ce soit une fausse info !)
C’est finalement la littérature et la sociologie qui nous donnent des pistes d’explications.
Et y a sûrement plusieurs raisons à cela... déjà vu qu’ils ne représentent que 2% de la population mondiale,
chercher si les roux ont une odeur corporelle différente,
ça me semble pas spécialement porteur comme sujet d’étude.
Mais surtout, ce serait se lancer dans une recherche qui stigmatise un ensemble de personnes
sur la base d’un caractère physique...
est-ce qu’on est vraiment sûrs que c’est une bonne idée ?
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo. J’espère que vous sentez bon.
Et n’hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire, partager, rejoignez-nous sur le Discord,
et puis si vous regardez cette vidéo à sa sortie,
on est en live tout de suite, je suis sur Twitch,
et vous pouvez venir discuter avec moi de mon odeur ou de la votre.
Et il fait vraiment une étude exhaustive des odeurs du corps, regarde :
“Pour ne rien omettre, mentionnons ici l'odeur du smegma préputial.
Fade et aromatique à la fois,
elle rappelle l'odeur de marée, d'écrevisse cuite.”
OK, non mais là c’est bon. Mais je vais manger dans l’autre maison. Allez salut.
Tu savais ça toi Marie ?
JE SUIS PAS ROUSSE LÉA, TU ARRÊTES AVEC ÇA !
Mais du coup, vous avez une âme.
Ok.